30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become
get fill on the app store or Google Play
hi everyone it's Joanna here so have you
guys completed the entire workout series
with our field trainers well today we're
going through a yoga power flow sequence
with Wendy we're gonna go through a
whole series of stretching flexibility
and strengthening in a beautiful flow of
breath and movement hey don't worry if
you're a beginner I'm gonna give you
options and we're gonna progress through
the entire workout easy to advance but
just take the options as and when you
need that's right I know I'm feeling
really tight and I will need this so
let's stretch together let's get started
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey we are ready to start your yoga
power flow so I need you to have your
feet out wide just like this and we've
got a lot of hard opening sequins coming
up because that actually opens the
breathing space and your body stretches
the chest and it takes you up from the
rounded shoulders so sink into your hips
push your knees and thighs out I need
you to stack the hands on top and we're
gonna circle behind nice and easy and
push to the side and again I'm gonna do
this a few times just to get you a nice
and warm so shift the weight in your
legs from Center to the side take a deep
breath in and as you breathe out push
away inhale to open the chest exhale to
push we want to keep moving get you nice
and warm and get you ready for what's
coming up next let's take it a little
bit more so this time take a look lift
the heels swing the arms and turn take a
deep breath in now look at my back heel
when you turn lift that back heel up
so that your knee follows the hip
and you do not hurt your knee as you do
this so are we still breathing
inhale
exhale roll it's like throwing your days
stresses away
breathing in and breathing out inhale
here exhale push let's do four more push
to the hands swing lift the back heel
two more to go
one last one
and that's it I need you to step over at
the top of your mat tailbone tuck under
so you can stand with your feet hip
distance if you want tailbone under
think of good posture we're always
lifting through the chest roll the
shoulders back take a deep breath in and
sit back into your chair imagine there's
a chair behind you push your bum back
your weight should be on your heels we
dive forward so open the arms out into
your forward fold Let the Body go hands
to your shins take a deep breath in here
and as you breathe out just melt come on
down
we're gonna step or jump back into
downward dog so let's start by stepping
back one foot at a time pushing your
thighs to the back wall lifting the hips
pressing into your hands and your feet
slide forward into your plank breathing
in with me
and as you breathe out drop to the knees
and remember to take this option
whenever you need we're lowering the
chest elbows into the ribcage hips down
to the floor roll the shoulders either
halfway up or all the way up pushing
into your hands straightening the arms
open the chest we go into downward dog
again lift the hips up
and I need you to stay here now
right leg comes up the leg closest to us
lift it up here into your three-legged
dog
we're going in knee to the nose so Slide
the weight forward knee in
crunch it in here treat it dog again
lift that leg up
one more to go knee in to the chest and
take a look we're gonna step that foot
between your hands if you can otherwise
use your hand to help your foot forward
come in into feet hip distance forward
fold
take a deep breath in come on up inhale
to reach to the top
exhale to open chair pose sitting back
lowering the hips lifting the arms
weight on your heels
diving forward arms open wide hips up
into your forward fold letting go
hands to shins we breathe in as you lift
the chest
breathing out slide your hands down Tuck
the chin and drop the crown of your head
step or jump back into your downward dog
and pushing your thighs through the back
wall lifting the hips pressing hands and
feet
ready come forward into your plank take
a nice deep breath in here and as your
lower knees can be on or off the floor
whatever feels good for you today hips
down shoulders back breathe push the
floor away
and as you exhale pushing back how high
can you lift the hips pressing through
the hands and feet stay here
until it comes up so left leg up this
time three-legged dog
knee in towards the face think about
punching into the ABS pushing through
the hands
leg up again into a three-legged dog
make sure you're pressing evenly on both
hands now
knee in towards the chest
we're gonna step forward and try to land
the foot between your hands or help it
through with the hands
feet hip distance coming forward exhale
into your forward fold
take a deep breath inward coming up
inhale standing up we reach to the top
and exhale to open we're going go into a
standing Warrior sequence so turn to the
front with your feet out wide
left foot turns in right foot out we're
going to Warrior Two so check to make
sure that the knee Stacks over your
ankle that's for knee safety hips to the
front think of it like your car
headlights
and always reach the arms up to the side
can you relax the shoulders here
sink a little lower if you can or stay
where you are we breathe in lift through
the hands remember heart opening poses
coming up so your hands just wrap around
your elbows
but check that you're rolling your
shoulders down away from the ears
take a deep breath in lift through the
chest we tip back now take a look at
this Top Hand I want you to use it to
pull the elbow back so you get a
beautiful stretch on the right side of
your body and that's where I need to
channel the breath now
did we come up I think you came out so
sink a little lower into the legs
releasing the back arm we're going to
Sun Warrior
I need you to lengthen and straighten
the top arm reach
good tip over elbow to the thigh
top arm over the ear
drop the hips with you and I want the
chest open by pushing the shoulder way
back if it's comfortable for you you can
look up if it doesn't feel good look to
the front but think about pushing that
little toe into your mat reaching that
hand out
come back up again and we've got the
other side so right foot turns in left
foot turns out hips to the front and
body is centered between your feet
sink into your hips arms wide to the
side think about rolling the thighs up
and back relax the shoulders inhale lift
and reach exhale grab the elbows now
check that you're not sticking your rib
cage out so I want that ribcage in
tailbone tuck lift to the chest breathe
in and as you exhale that Top Hand just
pulling that elbow just a little and
feel that beautiful stretch down the
left side of your body
releasing that arm just slightly touch
the back of your leg
top arms stretch and reach maybe go just
a little bit more sink into your hips
bend that knee lots to strengthen the
legs
come on up and over elbow to the thigh
top arm over your ear don't forget those
hips they need to sink down with you
don't leave them behind top shoulder
pushing back so either look to the front
or look up if it feels good for you
good how's that feel
slowly come back up we're gonna step
forward come back to the top of your mat
feet hip distance lift through the chest
roll the shoulders back and Sun
salutation this time we're gonna add
something for you take a deep breath in
sit back into your chair exhale drop
into your hips diving forward arms open
and softening melting
handstitions come up halfway you can
bend your knees
and slowly take the hands to the floor
step or jump back are you ready to jump
back let's try knees Bend jump back or
step back into your downward dog
coming forward for your plank breathe so
you know your options knees can be on or
off the floor but if you're lower elbows
into the rib cage work those triceps
hips down shoulders rolling back pushing
the floor away opening to the chest
downward dog again so lift the hips up
and stay here
three-legged dog right leg comes up the
leg closest to us lifting to the roof
check that you're pushing evenly on both
hands now
knee in towards the face curl in in and
crunch just like your mountain climber
lift that foot up again push your heel
down even pressure on both hands
knee in crunch it in come on pushing
through the hands to work arms and upper
body strength
step forward with the foot if you get
stuck is your option okay you can use
your hand to help through
Warrior three are you ready for this one
okay so back foot comes in I've got
options for you to get into it okay so
take a look hands to the Neo thigh
you ready one two three let's go join
our back leg comes up hold you can stay
here with the hands on your thigh or you
can reach your hands out
[Music]
check that your hips are level
hands down to the floor
yeah feet hip distance come on in into
your forward fold just let your whole
body go
we're gonna stand up so take a deep
breath in from the toes right up to the
hands
breathe chair pose exhale open sit back
sit low
take that dive forward arms wide
softening down just melt
hands to shins we breathe in as you lift
the chest
and as you breathe out just melt belly
to thighs letting go
you want to step or jump back downward
dog bend your knees step or jump back
you choose listen to your body
come forward for your plank take a deep
breath in
exhale to lower knees chest and Chin
it's coming down shoulders away from
ears inhale how much can you open the
chest squeeze the butt here
lift through the hips foot downward dog
we stay here now three-legged dog so
other leg comes up
pushing through the heel even pressure
on both hands
knee in towards the face yes I said face
lift your heel as high as you can even
pressure on both hands
knee into the face can you step the
forward now it should get a bit warm by
now yeah
hands ready you can slide in with the
hands here
pick up the back leg whenever you're
ready
hands can stay on your thighs or you can
reach out into your Warrior three
you're gonna feel it in your butt on
that standing leg
bend your knee Lots I want to see lots
of knee Bend for this one yes hello butt
muscle
hands down to the floor step forward
feet hip distance
come on up take a deep breath in Just
Breathe Right now all the way to the top
and exhale open
round two for your standing Warrior
sequence so feet out wide left foot
turns in no stopping now right foot
turns out arms out Warrior Two breathing
in
yes relax the shoulders make sure the
body is centered between your feet
knees stacked over the ankle arms wide
hand Palm up
and all the way to the side like as if
someone's pulling you to this side of
the room keep going keep going some more
some more right out to the edge and we
stuck yes we are elbow to the thigh top
arm over the ear Big Stretch guys
sink your hips down
we are going into a triangle
and it should look like one so hand you
can either hold your ankle like that or
if you want you can touch down okay so
feel free to experiment where the hand
should be and we're gonna straighten
lift lift lift open up
good press into your feet
if you can I need you to keep your hand
there
drop the hips because we are coming back
here arm over your ears sink the hips
down
ouch
straightening that leg push into both
feet open and reach
arm over the ear drop the hips
and again breathing in lift lift lift
lift
and breathing out sink the hips down
um over the ear
good job one more yes we need that one
oh can you feel the stretch on the inner
thigh so again join us
very nice look to the front or try
looking up it actually makes the pose
more challenging
oh reach look at the ceiling imagine
you're gonna touch the ceiling with the
hand all the way up
you're not gonna like me for the next
one half moon pose oh
bend your knee
hand to the hip just take support
that hand goes out but watch here you're
actually on your fingertips not on your
palm so on the fingertips back foot
slides in here so just take a look
before we do this I need you to lift
that leg up so just check to make sure
the hand is under your shoulder and then
whenever you're ready you're gonna lift
that leg up
so the option is to keep the foot down
yeah
or lifting the leg up
with the hand supporting here uh wobbly
wobbly is good
either that so take a look at the half
moon pose leg
reach so you're on the tip of your
fingers legs straight
it's much easier to look down to the
floor let's let's experiment where our
eye focus should be is it easier looking
down yes how about looking to the front
hello
big difference right lots of knee bin
because we're going to step back with
the foot
hikes hello butt muscle and leg
do you feel it oh yeah I'm clicking
I'm clicking you know what we have the
other side yes we do so right foot turns
in left foot turns out
sink always check yeah I know you hear
me say this all the time but knee has to
be stacked over your ankle for me safety
arms open breathing in
exhale relax the shoulders
left hand Palm up imagine someone's
pulling you to this side of the room go
for it go go go go go go just a bit more
if you think that's all try just a
little bit more there you go
elbow take support all the way up over
the ear
job triangle so you know what's coming
up yeah so if it's too much for you you
can actually grab just above your ankle
yeah or
if it's comfortable you can touch down
on the floor but open the chest by
pushing your shoulder back you're ready
triangle here we go push into the feet
and lift open
bend your knees sink your hips down arm
over the ear
I've got a tip for you let's try
triangle again so listen up guys
I want you to press your feet into the
mat like as if you're stretching the mat
with your feet now
that makes you work your inner thighs
more isn't it sink the hips so try to do
that every time you go into triangle
okay one more time
push into your feet like as if you're
stretching the mat with your feet
it actually activates your muscles more
try looking to the front
how's it feel when you look up give it a
go experiment with the pose reach a
little higher like as if you want to
touch the ceiling with your hand
well done
bend that knee sink the hips down
top arm just take support to the hip
we're going into half moon pose remember
oh
so back foot slides in here
hand under your shoulder just on the tip
of your fingers so you can just stay
here if you want yeah or you can lift
that leg with a hand on the hip so many
options for you to choose guys find
something that challenges you but you're
not falling over
okay or the other option is you can
touch down with the hand to the thigh
like this
or let's go straight into your half moon
pose straightening that standing leg
opening through the chest
and lift the arm
again where you look makes a huge
difference try looking down
looking to the front I'm not going to
look up because I know I'm going to fall
over
okay lots of knee pain and step back now
oh my goodness
oh
okay oh yeah okay feet hip distance
tailbone under lift to the chest roller
shoulders back take a deep breath in all
the way to the top
chair pose sit back sit low lift the
heads up hey we should start to get warm
by now yeah arms wide so what I'm asking
you is to go lowering your poses go
higher into your poses whatever okay so
let's go step back or jump back downward
dog lift the hips push your hands and
feet it feels different now right
compared to the first round come forward
for your plank we breathe in
things up a little faster exhale to
lower
inhale push the floor away lift
exhale to push way back hips up
stay here three-legged dog right leg
comes up even pressure on both hands
lean towards the face knee to nose come
on nose
lift heel up
good knee in
that's a tip for you if you can't step
your foot forward just lift your hip
higher and you should be able to get the
foot through okay
we have standing split oh boy
okay so here's how we do this walk your
hands forward and get your knees and
thighs together so just bend your knee
like this
this is level one see you've done level
one standing split yay
take it a little higher that's level two
are we gonna stay here
so choose you can just stay here in
level two the aim is actually to stretch
your hamstring on your standing leg
and you want to see level three let's go
for it standing split push and lift toes
right up legs straight drop the crown of
your head
and we are going to stay here for 15
minutes
oh my God
come back
walk the horse back straight away go
into your downward dog step back
plank position come forward breathe get
the breath going exhale to lower elbows
into the ribs inhale push the floor away
straightening the arms downward dog hips
up stay here three-legged dog either leg
comes up pushing
press evenly in both hands knee in to
the nose
lift the heel up again push
knee into the nose remember what I said
just now lift your hips up so you can
step the foot between the hands
standing split I think they are ready
for this one now back foot comes in Walk
the hands forward so your weight should
actually be more on your hands to help
you pick up that foot so your knees and
thighs are together level one standing
split level two a little halfway here
or let's do this level three all the way
up
you'll find that one side is much easier
than the other because we tend to have
lots of muscle imbalances yeah
15 minutes yes
bend your knee feet hip distance into
your forward fold
slight Bend in the knees guys I need you
to hug your elbows like that hold your
elbows tuck your chin in imagine you're
a rag doll and if you were to push the
doll over that's how you should look
we're gonna rock side to side
it's a beautiful stretch on your lower
back and your hamstrings
fall asleep doing this right
fall asleep she's got a few more to go
and to the floor just releasing
hands to shins just halfway up you can
bend your knees yeah if it is too much
of the stretch here
take a deep breath in to stand up
everyone inhale
and exhale to open I've got news for you
we've got some balancing poses coming up
quickly catch your breath you're gonna
need it balancing pose is excellent
because it strengthens you on one side
of the body it switches on your core
muscles it works mental strength and
focus so we've got three pose
I've got different levels in triples so
check this one out level one right leg
so you can on the floor keep it on the
floor or level two the heel is just
beside the knee
making sure that knees out in line with
the hip level three
foot to your inner thigh so press your
foot in like as if you're making
footprint on your inner thigh so that
you can push that knee out to the side
hands to your heart and find your Center
shoulders here we're gonna move the arms
to challenge you today open the arms out
take a deep breath in as you exhale
soften through the shoulders right up to
the fingers
breathe in lift to the top keep pushing
your foot into your mat like as if
you're making a footprint in the mat
slide your shoulder blades down your
back so you relax through the shoulders
can you find calmness and Stillness in
this pose
we're gonna peel the foot away
we've got a little martial arts feel
coming out so lift
here's level one you can grab hold the
back of your leg lift it up to help you
stand tall this is level one
and little martial arts field so we're
gonna let go take a deep breath in Palms
push exhale form that c shape with the
spine pressing through the hands
hold here again if you need to or touch
down ah there we go
that wasn't planned to be honest okay we
can come back here hold
piece fingers
hook onto your big toe ah you know what
to do with this so again options level
one stay here or here okay if you're
comfortable keep the knee bent
and let's go for it don't think so much
push through the heel I want you to lift
the chest gentle Stand Tall come on up
yes hold stay are you breathing are you
smiling smiling helps
yes yes
benjamini and gently place the foot down
whoa well done shake the legs out oh
gosh oh
and because we have two legs
okay
ready three pose so left leg so take the
easier option okay if you need to touch
down go ahead all right or halfway here
heel to the knee or all the way up I
need you to press your foot into your
inner thigh but you want to make a
footprint there because that's gonna
make you open that knee up to the side
making you walk your hips more okay you
could stand like this the whole day look
pretty
hands to your heart find your Center
take a deep breath and open to the side
and as you exhale melt through the
shoulders right out to the hands we
breathe in think of it like a tree
firmly rooted into the ground growing
right up to the sun reach lengthen the
arms strengthen the core and the leg
soften your shoulders down
balancing poses helps mental strength
and focus as well
good arms open to the side
you can release the foot here you can
grab hole this arm helps you to balance
and lift and stand tall
martial arts feel ready take a deep
breath in release the leg exhale push
form that c shape with the spine go for
it come on lift that knee up challenge
hold
well done reach the ten grab hold again
we're coming back here so you can stay
here with this option or you can
progress piece fingers
grab all of your big toe you can stay
here with the knee Bend can you see I'm
wobbling yes I'm wobbling
and one two three let's do this
Smiley helps
[Music]
the lift push through the heel chest up
come on how tall can you stand in this
pose press through the heel stay for
four
three
I know you're thinking why is she
counting so slow two and a half
two and release on one well done if you
stayed with us oh my gosh shake the legs
out I've got good news for you we're
gonna sit down
I'm not sure if that's good news but
take a seat with us okay oh
ready Swan pose we're gonna work around
the hips and butt and that's going to
help release tightness in your back as
well so I need you to turn this way with
a knee Bend now it can be 1990 if you're
really tight in the hips that's your
option if it feels good for you you can
straighten the back leg
but I need you to think about just put
your hand here on the hip and see if you
can manually adjust by Rolling that
thigh and kneecap to the floor
now wherever this foot is it doesn't
matter find something that feels good
for you when I say feel good it means
for the hip and butt
lift through the chest take a deep
breath in we are coming forward this
time so hand in front again level one
you can stay up on the hands here
take it down a little further on the
elbows
and you know where to go for the last
one reach the hands out and just melt
soften through the shoulders reach the
hands out
and think of that back leg see if you
can roll that knee and thigh towards the
floor
but reach your hands away as far as you
can go how far can the hands go away
from the toes
come back up so hands go under your
shoulders to help you come up
we tuck the foot in
we're going into a quad stretch quads
means the front thigh so pick up that
foot I like to do this
okay
so make sure this foot is tucked in and
I've got an option for you you're really
tight and you're struggling in this pose
lift your bum off the floor like this
but the hand has to support on the floor
okay so you can be here with the bum of
the floor or you can sit down with the
foot in and I want you to get your heel
into the butt
butt
heel meets butt okay the hand stays on
the floor but I need you to sit up as
tall as you can so that stretches in the
front of the hip where you're squeezing
the muscles here the hip and butt
and if you want it to look a bit more
yoga
if you can't get the hands if you can
interlock and class like this if you
can't get the hands here don't worry put
the hand down still looks good I promise
you
okay so you can be here on the floor
with Joanna or you can do this with me
but try not to sink into your back so
lift the chest
class the hands and again give us that
smile
smell through the pain yes hey it's a
good kind of pain so you need to smile
hands down slowly and always release the
foot gently oh my gosh next one I know
you're gonna find this weird but it's
called cow face pose so in here slide
that right knee over so what I need you
to do it helps actually I find that
helps if I lean forward into my hands I
squeeze my thighs to get them together
and sit back
okay did you get it yes and you should
be resting on the outer edge of your
feet making sure both butt cheeks are on
the floor so stick that right bump down
lift through the chest nice and Tall
hands at the side softening through the
shoulders this is really good for your
hip and butt as well as the lower back
I'm gonna move you now so take a deep
breath in left arm reach up and over now
careful with this shoulder make sure
you're not hyped up like this so soften
that shoulder down tip over only as far
as you can go the hand can move if you
want or stay in
come back up breathe in
lightly just touch your back
holding the tip of the elbow take a deep
breath in lift through the chest and
we're going again form that c shape with
the spine feel that stretch down your
tricep and the left side of your body
check to make sure you're sitting down
on the right bum
come back up again this hand goes to the
back
okay and if you can see if you can clasp
your hands like this okay yeah if you
cannot that's perfectly fine whatever
your hands land just let them be or if
you have a towel grab all of the towel
grip it keep practicing with the towel
one day if you keep practicing you'll
find that your fingers and your hands in
class all right take a deep breath in
chest up and as you exhale just melt
come forward with us
keep the elbows up
slowly release the hands to the floor
take a deep breath in and as you exhale
slide your hands forward now you will
feel your bum lift off the floor we
don't want that see if you can press
gently into your hands and sit back so
try to get your bum back on the floor in
this pose
come on in hands and come back up okay
release the legs ah ouch untangle the
legs now
okay okay we are good
you can shake the legs out if you want
yeah we have Swan pose on the other side
okay so over here just make sure that
you're doing the other side don't do the
same side that will be terrible
okay so where the foot is it's really up
to you doesn't matter you can bend 1990
as well or you can extend the back leg
everybody hand here to the hip to
manually adjust and see if you can roll
that thigh and kneecap to the floor
take a deep breath in lift through the
chest
hands come forward so you can just stay
here if you want or feel free to
experiment the pose
either on your elbows you can do that
too lots of options remember or you can
reach the hands out and just melt into
the floor literally melting the floor
relax the shoulders
breathe into those areas that you feel
tense
or tight I want you to channel the
breath there
hands under the shoulders to help you
come back up
when tucking the front foot in
rolling the foot out
get your heel in towards the butt and
the hand is close to the hip to support
and lift you up in this pose so the
option remember you can lift your bum
off the floor with the hand supporting
or you can sit down push your foot into
your hand get it in so you can even hold
so many options guys so take the option
that challenges you
hand can be on the floor or take a deep
breath in lift up and see if you can
clasp
keep opening the chest lift the body try
not to sink
and slowly release
slowly release the foot okay
then slide that knee here swinging that
leg from the back to the front
and again it helps if you just come
forward like that so that you can
squeeze your thighs together take a seat
yes and you're resting on the outer edge
of your feet make sure both butt cheeks
are on the floor you can give it a
little wiggle
hands out here like this relax through
the shoulders you ready right hand up
take a deep breath and move breath and
movement exhale tip over relax that
shoulder
come back up breathe in and just lightly
touch your back the other hand holding
the tip of the elbow we want to sit tall
so inhale lift through the collarbones
exhale form that c shape with the spine
for Mobility feel that stretch on the
tricep all the way down to the right
side of your body
come back up again
try this one see if your hands can clasp
or you've got a towel grab the towel
okay or wherever your hands land on your
back just just let it be lift through
the chest
good exhale tip forward keep lifting
your elbow try not to drop the elbow
here
gently release the hands to the floor in
front of you
take another breath in with us and as
you exhale Slide the hands away but sit
back if you find your bum lifting off
the floor push it slightly into your
hands and sit back
especially that left bump try to stick
your left hip and butt into the floor
how far can your hands go in this pose
hands under your shoulders and slowly
come back up
release the legs here
good
we have one more frog pose
have we done frog pose I've done it it's
something new as always the first time
so take a look so basically I need knees
open as wide as you can okay
and if you want you can actually fold
towels and put it under your knees if it
hurts you okay but I want knees or white
seriously white okay this is really good
for your hips and butt stretches the
inner thighs releases tightness in your
back so I need you on your elbows
look at my feet toes up make sure you
flex your feet so you align your knee
with your ankle okay so nice and strong
there
do not sink into your shoulders so guys
check this out push through the arms
lift the chest and I want you to tuck
that tailbone under so that you're not
sinking into your lower back so tailbone
under yes
this is fructose
okay listen it's not gonna be that easy
right you know it push through the knees
you'll find that your hips lift up
oh boy then as you exhale I want you to
slowly slide your knees out to the side
okay if it's stuck give it a little move
one more time let's try this yeah tail
won't tuck under lift to the belly push
both knees into the mat really strong
you'll feel your hips lift that's fine
press your knees into the mat come on
squeeze
and as you exhale slightly see if your
knees can slide out a little further out
they say good things happens in three so
third round ready push through the arms
knees stick it into your mat like as if
you want to make imprints of your knees
now how would you do that can you feel
it in your inner thighs your groin tuck
the tailbone and then slowly see if you
can move your knees further out
oh
and one more this time I need you to
walk your elbows back what yes you hurt
me walk your elbows back move your hips
back into reverse gear oh my goodness oh
it's okay if you make some noise I
totally get it one more time ready move
your elbows back one two one elbow other
elbow sit back with the hips yikes
are we smiling
is she smiling
yes you must be thinking how can I smile
this pose it takes practice trust me and
there is a perfect way to come out of
this pose without hurting yourself
[Laughter]
so okay
please don't get stuck because I cannot
save you move your elbows forward lean
forward like this wait up one step at a
time okay
tuck your feet in so your toes meet
and by one one knee at a time
come up on your hands one at a time and
you know what I feel like a frog though
okay
oh my gosh Wendy you really stretched me
out from all different angles
I really enjoy that I mean I have really
tight hamstrings and glutes and I really
feel that deep stretch right into my
hamstrings and glutes so I'm sure I'm
gonna feel a lot better tomorrow I
really enjoyed this session let me know
how you guys felt in the comments below
okay and what was your favorite pose hey
guys I know some of the poses were a
little bit challenging but feel free to
take the options keep practicing I
promise you will get better yeah I think
I'm gonna be doing this video at least
once a week just to incorporate it into
my workout routine as well you should
yeah so if you want more yoga and
pilates videos from Wendy then do check
out the fuel app download it for free on
the App Store or Google play or go and
check out our website feellive.com for
amazing discounts okay and don't forget
to also hit the Subscribe button if you
haven't done it like this video share
this workout with your friends and also
if you want more videos from Wendy and I
then let us know in the comments below
thank you so so much thank you keep
practicing guys we'll see you my glutes
are on fire
[Music]